Mọi người là thì cách nghiêm cạnh cảo không về cạnh lớp, có rất là cạnh nhiều.
Hành khong có trị tây mà khi có trị tây là chúng ta sẽ có đủ đồ sáng ở lình tình.
Trong nên là trong đời sống này từ bảo khi đời được cạnh có trị tây.
Đồng hợi nó thì chúng ta tính trung là phung có trị nghĩa là là chung sạc đi cái tâm trí.
Vào, đêm người sửa chung tình được thông thông.
Đồng hợi nó là thị bụt khu lẽ nào khi có trị chống có trị trung được phải là...
...tỉ có như thông dễ, nó là được kiên tình tính lạnh và tập trung lạnh cho con người có sự trang nghiêm.
Và chúng ta người giống có không đi, của bạn tính trung có tính tính này.
Hính sự cầu những cái bật cao gái.
Hồi từ đó cầu những tình đất cho mà người khòi nhẹ.